[Applause]
[Music]
our rituals our culture is uh connected
to this uh herum rice the her rice
project is one of the seven uh variety
projects of the Department of
Agriculture in the the international
rice research uh Institute in the
absence of short-term projects like the
heirloom project they could well be at
risk of Disappearing this aom rise
project is definitely a gift of the
Philippines to the world
[Music]
I am Mrs anah habing of baranga am ganad
I'm married with six children and I have
also 12
grandchildren uh I am the leader of the
farmer here in Aman it is a respect to
our grandparents and without them we
should not be what we are so we have to
maintain the traditional rice
This research project of Erie and uh the
Department of Agriculture are of
significant because it will empower the
farmers get them organized so that they
will attain that economies of the scale
of late Market says that there is high
demand for uh aom rice and it even
command a higher price than the rice
variety that cultivated in the lowland
so there is a great opportunity for our
uh farmers at the upand community to
access uh the nich market which caters
to uh
[Music]
rice there is an existing market and we
believe that the market is even
expanding we're trying to get the
so-call geographical indication for
specific um traditional varieties so
this is like wine appellation where you
can really identify a particular ular
variety to a specific territory where it
is originating from and this is very
important for the farmers and for the
consumer life because we can know we can
trace where the products are coming from
and who's growing the varieties and the
location where the varieties are getting
the traits that they are known
for tourists are coming we are actually
helping the lodging in the manawi hotel
and we are helping people who are
involved in the tourism activities we
are helping them indirectly that's why I
convince the farmers that we should also
we should be active also and Revive Our
custom and tradition in farming we
return back our native rice we return
back all the fishes the delicious uh
foods that are growing in the rice field
and sell it and sell it to
the to the visitor so but while the
other people are gaining from the
tourist you are also
gaining this arum rice project is a
winwin win situation for Erie Erie got
to learn more about this um Alum rice
varieties particularly the traits the
unique traits that they carry to the
farmers because the farmers are getting
will be getting more from their produce
and they will be able to showcase their
culture their tradition to the world and
third to the consumers because they are
going to get the health benefits and
other important rats that these alom
rice varieties can provide it is a win
for the Philippines also for the
country the value of these heirloom
varieties comes from combining them with
the communities where they have been
traditionally grown the practices those
communities have used for growing them
their whole cultur is built around them
and and those heirloom varieties are ESS
central part of those communities their
whole life whereas when you bring those
varieties here into the gene Bank all we
brought is the genetic material we
haven't got the knowledge of those
communities we haven't got the rest of
the farming system that they're
maintaining we've just got the genes
what ought to happen is that we combine
their knowledge with our knowledge and
that would allow us to produce a package
of improved varieties and improved
agricultural methods that combine the
best of both
worlds in the Corda they own the seeds
like you go from one family they have a
selection of seeds that were passed on
to them from generation to generation
and you look at them and say like you're
looking at the gem every grain that is
sold really goes back to the farmers
because the way that our our NGO and the
market is set up is that there is a
dividend sharing sharing to all the
stakeholders the farmers the NGO and the
and the consumer and so all of that
plays into part when they sell the rice
and they you buy the rise at the premium
price if we lose the farmers if we lose
the teres if we lose all these earlom
grains we are poor what is Filipino food
is what grows in our environment and
what people do to it I want you to be
feel that you're eating the Tera of this
country you want to taste the
Philippines you want to taste the food
this
grew from our land this was stealed by
Philippine Farmers the DNA of these
grains come from our forefathers
[Music]